My name is Paloma Robles Lacayo and I am
the director of the Museum of the Mummies of
Guanajuato the Museum of the Mummies of
Guanajuato is a sacred site that
exhibits a collection of natural mummies
with android seventeen bar and
mission center state lord is collection
jackson no mix  in the world
the measure of walker being permanent
divulge alternating with breaking mexico in
english
table tennis hacking en face
come to seek that intimate experience
that mystical encounter with death that
fosters reflection on the
intensity of their own life and
meaning  of the same it is important
that people are not afraid of
death and on the contrary see it as a
natural phenomenon as an
inevitable transition of their existence because
they will finally meet it